[Music]
thank you the Barden Bellas an unlikely
group of not men who somehow managed to
win it something that didn't have to do
with baking I can hear you bit graduated
cars have spread their wings that are
attempting to fly to five layers delight
with a shot of white privilege hopefully
not becoming the failures we all expect
them to be I feel really good about
where I'm at right now I'm trying to get
into vet school fingers crossed
where are they now my name is fat Amy
Winehouse so let's get cracking I quit
my job you got fine no I quit it's fine
I would do anything to sing with you
guys again
anything you guys every year the USO
puts on this performance to support the
troops in Europe what if I could get us
an invite yeah I've suddenly got a bunch
of free time so
we've never competed against bands that
actually have instruments so what's the
plan you guys just sing other people's
songs like karaoke
Harry oh that's so cute calamity this is
serenity Brasserie and charity if I
joined your group I could be a beast
another day on stage for the Bellas this
is their big plummet their fade out into
nothingness sure with us have I ever let
you down all the time
you're very unreliable it's like one of
the hallmarks of your personality you're
not remembering all the times I've been
awesome
let's hock a finish this
[Music]
try to have some dignity
yeah well we don't do anything with
dignity okay they really do need to join
the workforce yes you guys are seeing
other people's songs right oh my god um
guys stop they just don't like sharing
the spotlight so they're trying to
intimidate us let's just take the high
road and do what we do I think what I'm
thinkin money's like a riff-off
[Music]
coming up so you go
[Music]
[Music]
here's the most amazing group of women I
have ever known
I'm gonna do anything to sing with you
guys again
wait wait wait wait wait I'm having a
crazy idea
okay I've mentioned that my dad is in
the army and like basically tell us ama
bin Laden write some no information in
that sentence but okay well what I mean
is he's kind of a big deal in the army
and every year the USO puts on this
performance to entertain and support the
troops and this year dj khaled is
hosting he's got look at that gazillion
hit songs and he's super famous I saw
him on a tax commercial what if I could
get us an invite just say no to run
military dark ops yes of course to say
that's the ladder that'll take you up to
the main deck with the Bellas I do not
live fergus he what I'm doing below okay
giant distraction coming up you sure
about this why am i let you down dozens
of example spring to mind if I'm honest
yeah you're very unreliable it's like
one of the hallmarks of your personality
I don't think we have time to unpack
that right now Shh I'll just say up top
nobody's gonna die tonight right Yeah
right yeah well that doesn't help okay
okay ready
I've got my serious face on there okay
it's time let's do it
we were always gonna be there for each
other it's for family Becca don't I
swear to God don't make that face if you
cry I'm gonna cry
I'm not gonna do this with you today so
I hate that face how much I love you you
just get out there and you crush it okay
you crush it so hard that your lips
tingle a bit
all right ladies pick up your tips we're
going out what do you mean going out
what do you mean what do I mean we just
sucked balls in front of DJ Khaled huh
listening he's staying at that fancy
casino hotel across the street okay I
say we all get up we get dressed we go
over there and we show him that we are
not a joke Emily I can't believe that a
half-decent ID came out of your dumb
mouth thank you okay so let's get tot it
up it's had it and toss it gently toss
it up she means to she's a caramel tart
she's a chocolate taught you're the
vanilla Todd thanks babe hmm Oh hearted
targets easy I will just say [ __ ] and
as predicted Gail the Bellas are in over
their heads lost in a sea of seamen but
about mama
bounce we need thorough dance we need
girl keep me but about mom come on come
on
[Music]
baby I'm not a baby
[Music]
what about artists didn't know we're
Jewish so on the tour we've got three
bands say hey to the new group hello
bread the Bellas formerly a Barden
University and currently of life you
guys are seeing other people's songs
right oh my god um guys stop they just
don't like sharing the spotlight so
they're trying to intimidate us think
what I'm thinkin what is that a reef off
yes yes what is it a riff off is a
little game that we like to play let me
start with a beat oh yeah oh go ladies
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
with my Bella
[Music]
is that feedback
so it's singing guys still need that
level check for vocals on baby we're
just getting started
[Music]
[Applause]
I was fine and
they just call it by themselves by using
musical instruments because dad we won
guys we should go
we fellas are doing what they do best
quitting here's the problem John the
Bellas are not as good as the other
bands that is a startling insight
all right ladies were going to show them
that we are not a joke let's finish this
try to have some dignity we don't do
anything with dignity okay
what a beautiful for every one of them
going nowhere tonight about this day we
didn't invite you guys to sing we
invited you to watch excuse me I just
thought you guys were so busy with your
awesome jobs and amazing lives I am
actually they're so bright and shiny
still they look like they was all
breastfed you're the USO cuts on this
performance to support the troops in
Europe one last show together
who's with me oh yeah welcome to Spain
Bella's so this is the first base will
we be going to second base with you guys
that's a note from me so on the tour
we've got three bands you guys are
seeing other people's songs right like a
cover band they're trying to intimidate
us let's just do it - every false run
enhancing of troll
we like to keep it oral
is that where that everybody is better
at the one thing that we do then then we
are at that thing all right ladies pick
up your tests we're going to show them
that we are not a joke my record label
wants to sign one of the bands though we
don't want the balance we want you what
I did not see this coming
failing we support each other we like
sisters Aubrey
he is Aubry isn't it I can't I'm part of
a group Becca it's a big opportunity for
you
[Applause]
[Music]
bye-bye Bella's it really does feel like
a bhaijaan thangka what are you doing
don't ya
if you cry I'm gonna cry don't make that
face
I'm not doing it
[Music]